MEDIA.
BIT COIN AND EMOJIS, BRIAN.
BRIAN: LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC ACCORDING TO DR. FAUCI
NEVER GETS BETTER.
CAUTIONING VACCINATED AMERICANS
AGAINST INDOOR DINING.
>> IF YOU ARE DRINKING INDOORS
AND RESTAURANTS AND BARS, IS
THAT OKAY NOW?
>> NO, IT’S STILL NOT OKAY FOR
THE SIMPLE REASON THAT THE LEVEL
OF INFECTION, THE DYNAMICS OF
INFECTION IN THE COMMUNITY ARE
STILL REALLY DISTURBINGLY HIGH
AND IF YOU ARE VACCINATED,
PLEASE REMEMBER THAT YOU STILL
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL AND NOT GET
INVOLVED IN CROWDED SITUATIONS,
PARTICULARLY INDOORS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE NOT WEARING MASKS.
BRIAN: IT’S EXASPERATING.
HOW WILL THE MIXED MESSAGE
IMPACT BUSINESSES JUST TRYING TO
RECOVER?
IS THAT A RESPONSIBLE STATEMENT?
LET’S BRING IN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR DR. MARTY MAKARY.
DR. MAKARY WE WERE TOLD LAST
WEEK BY THE CDC IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED YOU CAN’T TRANSFER
THE VIRUS.
WE ARE TOLD YOU CAN’T TRANSFER
THE VIRUS FROM INANIMATE IT
OBJECTS.
WIPING DOWN GROCERIES FOR SO
REASON.
NOT HAVE TO WEAR MASKS LET ALONE
NOT TO GO INDOORS.
WAS THAT TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> GOOD MORNING, BRIAN, YOU ARE
HEARING MIXED MESSAGING, AS A
RESULT OF THE LOT OF THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS ARE SEEING
INFECTION SPREAD YOUNG PEOPLE.
A LOT OF THE GUIDANCE HAS LOST
CREDIBILITY.
THE ISRAELI STUDY IS IN NOW OUR
OWN NIH DR. FAUCI’S NIH DID NOT
FUND THESE STUDY LOOKING AT
TRANSMISSION NOW WE DON’T HAVE
TO GUESS.
THE DATA IS IN AND RISK OF
TRANSMISSION FROM THAT ISRAELI
STUDY IS NEGLIGIBLE.
I CAN TELL YOU, BRIAN, AS A
COCHRAN, YOU HAVE GOT TO GIVE
PEOPLE SOMETHING TO LOOK
FORWARD.
TO SAY IF YOU JUST TELL THEM
THEY CAN’T DO STUFF, IT’S NOT
RIGHT.
YOU HAVE GOT TO TELL THEM HOW TO
DO THINGS SAFELY AND BE IN STEP
WITH WHAT THEY’RE GOING TO DO.
BRIAN: DR. MAKARY, WHETHER YOU
HAVE A MEDICAL DOCTOR ON YOU
SHOULD HAVE A PSYCHOLOGIST ON,
TOO.
LOOK AT ANYONE STUDYING BEHAVIOR
IF I’M GOING TO THE BAR AND
LEAVE AT 11:00 THE VIRUS ONLY
SPREADS AFTER 11:00 I GO HOME
WHERE WE HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT IN
HOME SPREAD IS THE BIGGER
PROBLEM, CORRECT?
DO PEOPLE WANTS TO EVER GAME
PLAN THIS OUT?
>> WE’RE ABOUT TO ENTER A BIG
NATIONAL ARGUMENT.
THAT IS WHEN THE HOSPITALS HAVE
BASICALLY NO COVID PATIENTS BUT
THE VIRUS CONTINUES TO CIRCULATE
YOUNG PEOPLE ASYMPTOMATIC OR
MILD SYMPTOMS IS THAT A HEALTH
EMERGENCY OR NOT?
YOU WILL SEE A NATIONAL ARGUMENT
BREAK OUT OVER THE MONTH OF MAY
OTHER THAT BECAUSE THAT’S
PROBABLY WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN
OVER MAY.
SO THERE IS TRADEOFFS.
IT’S NOT A MATTER OF WE’RE BEING
OVERLY CAUTIOUS CAUTION IS GOOD.
THERE IS TRADEOFFS AND LET ME
KNOW IF YOU EVER HEAR DR. FAUCI
OR DR. WOLENSKI EVER TALK ABOUT
SUICIDE FROM KIDS GETTING SHUT
OUT FROM.
BUSINESSES BEING STARVED OR FROM
THE HARM OF PROFOUND ISOLATION.
THEY DON’T TALK ABOUT THAT.
BRIAN: LET ME THROW A STAT AT
YOU IN MARCH EMPLOYMENT IN
EATING AND DRINKING
ESTABLISHMENTS RESTAURANT, BARS,
1.8 MILLION JOBS BELOW
PRE-PANDEMIC LEVELS.
74 MILLION PEOPLE FULLY
VACCINATED.
22% OF THE POPULATION, OVER I
THINK ON SATURDAY OR SUNDAY, WE
GOT 4 MILLION IN ONE DAY.
YET, WE STILL HAVE OUR MEDICAL
OFFICIALS WALKING AROUND WITH
TWO MASKS.
WHAT KIND OF INCENTIVE IS THAT
TO GET PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE
FENCE TO GET VACCINATED?
WHAT CHANGES?
I STILL HAVE TO GO HOME AND SIT
ALONE WITH A DOUBLE MASK MAKE IT
SIMPLE GET VACCINE WAIT A MONTH
FOR THAT KICK IN AND HAVE A
NORMAL LIFE.
IF SOME BUSINESSES WANT TO HAVE
MASK POLICY INDOOR PUBLIC
GATHERING RESPECT THAT FOR A FEW
MORE WEEKS UNTIL WE GET TO A
BETTER SPOT.
LIVE A NORMAL LIFE.
THAT’S WHY PEOPLE SHOULD GET
VACCINATED AND DEAL WITH VACCINE
LIBERATE PEOPLE.
BRIAN: DON’T TELL US THAT YOU
CANNOT SHED THE VIRUS ONCE YOU
ARE VACCINATED AND THEN TELL US
DON’T GO ANYWHERE, DON’T GO TO
AN ESTABLISHMENT.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY RESTAURANTS
ARE LOSING SOMEWHERE ELSE OF
DOLLARS BECAUSE OF THIS
ARBITRARY 11:00 AMERICAN DOCTOR
A DOLL OF HIMSELF OUT THERE
CIRCULATING WHICH HE THINKS IS
HYSTERICAL TELL US NOT TO GO TO
THOSE PLACES?
DO YOU KNOW PEOPLE HAVE LEASES
DUE.
RESTAURANTS WANT TO HIRE
EMPLOYEES.
THEY ORDER FOOD AND THEN
DR. FAUCI TELLING PEOPLE TO STAY
HOME?
THAT’S TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> WELL, I WILL TELL YOU, BRIAN,
I DON’T THINK IT’S
REPRESENTATIVE OF HOW EVERYDAY
DOCTORS THINK.
A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE ARE
MAKING ALL THE DECISIONS HERE.
BRIAN: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> THEY MAY BE VERY GOOD AT
VIROLOGY BUT THEY DON’T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION
SCIENCE ABOUT PUBLIC POLICY
POVERTY VACCINATION.
WE HAVEN’T DONE A GREAT JOB
RATIONING THE SCARCE RESOURCES.
BRIAN: DR. MAKARY, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>> THANKS, BRIAN.
BRIAN: DEADLY MISTAKE CLAIMS THE
LIFE OF A 20-YEAR-OLD IN
MINNESOTA.
CALLS FOR DUE PROCESS ARE
FALLING ON DEAF EARS WITH